Good evening councilmember Shane Davis, Director of Urban Economic Development.
So tonight the administration wants to provide you and the public an update on
one of the larger construction projects we have going on in the city and that's
the Northern Bypass as we refer to it locally but it's actually the extension
of State Route 255. So remind everybody the overall scope of the project is four
and a half miles of new limited access highway from Pulaski Pike to about a
thousand feet east of US 231-431. Original project cost was 43 million
dollars. The project replaces the existing two lane Bob Wade lane that was
a local road both in the city and portions of it being in unincorporated
Madison County. The construction includes the relocation and replacement of
utilities, new water, new gas, electric and communication relocation. As I
mentioned four and a half miles a new curb and gutter roadway and then
multiple new road intersections along the corridor. The arrow that you see to
the right kind of shows the the current stage as of about 30 days ago. I think
this aerial shows a good scope of work of what is going on. We'll work from the
top part of the of the photo and down so in yellow the two areas you can see the
new portion that is actually open to traffic. So to the top of the screen
would be Memorial Parkway or US 231. Bottom of the screen would be getting
close to Pulaski Pike. You can see where the new intersections at Mount Lebanon
and Northgate Drive will connect and then in the black box you can see the
light gray that's the old Bob Wade Lane that this road project is replacing. I
will tell you contractors and crews are in the most difficult section of the
project and that is cutting through the upper the lower slope of the mountain
side. You can you can see as we get into some of these additional photos. Again
this is near Mount Lebanon Road intersection you can start to see on the
left-hand side the divided four-lane highway coming to the west and then
just to the right side of the screen you can see the old Bob Wade Lane and the
new that would be the new westbound two lanes. This is the part that is really we
knew would slow the progress of the project down. It's cutting through the
mountain slope very similar to a Cecil Ashburn widening project. The
contractor is hammering and busting rock and processing on site for roadbed
material but this type of construction is very slow in for the amount of
productivity. Here for the next couple of slides I'm going to show you the portions
that are complete and open to traffic. To the left would be going westbound
towards Pulaski Pike where Facebook and Metta and Toyota Motor Manufacturing and
L3 Harris North Huntsville Industrial Park and to the right you're you're
moving towards the Parkway. Again so this is the new 255. I will point out the two
lane road just in the upper part is the old Bob Wade Lane that will reconnect
will stay a local portion. We will once the project is complete we will identify
this road as Council Lady Watkins met with the neighbors. Locally it will be
called Bob Wade Lane. It will have State Route 250 signage so we will at the
point that we dedicate this road comes open to public we will need to rename
that two lane portion. And the Sharp family had indicated they would be open
Miss Watkins has we've made no commitment but the Sharp family has
lived on that road for a very long time so that could be an option but certainly
this council will make that determination. There's plenty time to do
that. As I move a little further you can see the intersection of US 231 431 and
State Route 255 when we bid the project we put this as an early completion or
or requiring the contractor to work from this intersection westbound. So that's
why you see everything near the Parkway is complete. Four-way traffic is moving
and then we transition as we get further west as we approach Pulaski Pike
back to the two lane as we're continuing to do construction. You see that work is
progressing on North Huntsville Village or North Village Town Center. The first
phase being anchored by Home Depot and Target and Food City to the bottom. So
again this is just a better close-up of the intersection that is complete. Heavy
amount of traffic already getting diverted westbound seeing this as an
alternate route in the mornings to get to Research Park Redstone Arsenal the
western corridor of our city. Project summary you know as once complete this
section will be significant to our community as far as transportation
network. It will complete a 14 mile loop of limited access highway from
Interstate 565 to US 231 and what I mean by limited access is as we go through
major intersections like University Drive and Highway 53 those overpasses
already in place. So from US 231 to Interstate I-565 other than the signal at
Mount Lebanon that I showed you earlier and Pulaski Pike it travels much like an
interstate system. Project status is about 75% complete. We're currently
scheduled for the calendar days contractually of November 2026. We have
had you know some inclement weather this summer a lot of rain. This is a federal
aid project so we probably will add some days to that but as you can see we're
getting really close. The hardest part around the mountain toe once that rock
is excavated most utilities are complete Huntsville utilities likes just a little
bit with electric there near Toyota area but most utilities are in place so that's
usually the slowest part and the good thing is those have been moved now for
about six months in totality. I'll answer any questions the council may have on
the project. Yes one of the questions as well first of all thank you Mr. Davis
for that presentation. A couple of people have been asking me about the
northern bypass. I thought the best thing to do was just to have an update in
council chambers. Yes ma'am. So we're 75% complete and I was going to ask you but
you said we're running a couple of days behind because of inclement weather. Do
you still project this to be completed in November? We are pushing both the
contractor and the engineering department to be completed by this calendar year.
I will just point out that I know engineering is working through it. This
this is probably the best illustration so the geotech naturally showed rock in
this area it's the toe of the mountain so would be what you would expect but as
you see along the tree line it's not solid rock so the design plans for this
project had much like Cecil Asperin we would drill shoot the rock and it would
leave a stone face a rock face along that with no treatment needed much like
you'd see on Governor's Drive you see on Cecil Asperin naturally you see that is
not the case it's what we refer to in engineering is a mixed face it's partly
dirt partly rock so we are working on a supplement plan of how to stabilize that
it could be slope paved it could be riprap the state will do that it's the
state highway so that would add a little bit of time but what we are focused on
is maintaining schedule of the road itself and get traffic on it this would
be outside the traffic lane and we believe could be done without not
withholding opening the road so as we get through the next couple months I
continue to update you but everybody is focused to get the road finished and
traffic going both directions by the end of calendar year. Okay and I've been
traveling through that road and I'll tell you that I have seen that it has
come a long ways. It looks good it looks really good. The other question I have is how's this going to help commute time for travelers who are traveling to Redstone
Arsenal? So as far as travel distance versus if you live in the northern part
of the city or northern part of the county today you're traveling US 231
you're coming through I-565 and then headed westbound our traffic modeling
for this project which the Federal Highway requires us to estimates and that's
computer generation modeling but cuts 15 minutes off that commute time because
it's more of a direct route but it one of the things I do I want to answer your
questions of course but then I want to give you a quick update just two slides
of what we knew would happen one this is going to move a lot of traffic which we
need in a growing community but we knew is also going to be an economic
development generator as most major arterials do in any city and I will show
that momentary I want to take your questions first. Okay that's all I have
now thank you for presentation. Yes ma'am. Mr. Merida. I just have a couple of quick
ones could you show me the reconfigured intersection at Mount Lebanon it seems
like it well if you could just show me that. It's best here. Yeah so I'm assuming
where the road goes to the north from this perspective yes that's going to be
the new intersection correct? It will so you see the current T
intersection of Mount Lebanon the two-lane of Bob Wade so think of that
two-lane direction of Bob Wade remaining becoming the new two-lane
westbound of 255 you see where the construction equipment and the new
gravel that is eastbound towards the parkway there will be an asphalt median
between those two travels right turning movements in that median so think of a
highway like a 431 US 72 it would act very similar to say Nance Road in 72 in
your district that's what it will look like. Okay. Full turning movements both
turning movements will directly go into Mount Lebanon or will there be like a
little u-turn that someone knows it will be a conventional signalized
intersection full turning movements excellent thank you because a little I
got misled by that service road sure you were going to drop it that's good
point okay my other question is the tie-in to 565 is going to be on right
out road by the the gates to the arsenal in Bridge Street that's that's right
yeah that will be the terminus of state route 255 thank you. This is a great road
project and I guess next to councilmember Watkins I'm biggest cheerleader of it
it's going to be great and I can see where it's what it's going to mean to the
community okay now let's say this gets wrapped up roughly around November
looking ahead are y'all starting to work plan toward I guess what we would call
the eastern bypass over towards highway 72 east and over to Hampton Cove my
ultimate goal is it's a ring road around the city that would take stress off of
the center part of the city yes sir we are so we refer to this as the northern
bypass phase one from Pulaski pot us 231 we are at 60% set of plan completion
for phase two which will go from us 231 to Winchester Road in Moore'sville Road
we Kathy Martin I just got confirmation about 30 days ago after meeting with
Mark Bartlett Federal Highway with having federal funds you have to have
what is called a logical term and I meaning where you would pick up the next
phase and where federal highway says you can in the next phase well the issue is
is when you model this and the amount of traffic will be diverted off I-5 65 and
come through this corridor the logical term and I would be us highway 72 our
argument has been that becomes a significant cost project in the tune of
180 million dollars we want to move local traffic so we've been advocating
for a year to say letter let our next phase to go from the Parkway to
Winchester Moore'sville we can obtain funding it's a little bit of right away
they're large track owners and we can fund that now it's taken a long time but
confirmation about two weeks ago that federal highway's gonna let's move
forward that's so to answer your question mr. clean we believe that we
can bid that project next year which would get us to Winchester Moore'sville
Road which will help alleviate if you see what we're doing even though we got
our own malfunction junction of I-5 65 and US 231 it's about 350 million dollar
project these type projects are you know if we can move 15,000 cars out of that
interchange a day and give an alternate route it helps South Huntsville helps
downtown it helps East Huntsville and West Huntsville that come through that
interchange every day because it's the nerve center of North Alabama North
South East West so we're advocating for that the eastern bypass that would come
from Hampton Cove to US 72 we've completed a corridor study we know what
the alignment will look like we've sent sent that off how it will tie to US 72
to ALDOT there are actually funding in the cap plan to start design plans for
that next year that you approved they were approved in 2025 but we've been
waiting for the corridor study and getting a federal highway and ALDOT to
approve where we would tie to US 72 before we start the design and that's
occurred this year I guess I'm hoping for the day down the line when Huntsville
has a ring road eastern bypass come around Arsenal East connector come back
on the ring road that takes stress off the medical district and all the other
portions of the city and I think that would really you know just remake
Huntsville and take traffic flow improvement but we're working on all you
guys are doing some great things not fast enough of course yeah but all y'all
they're all in progress I think we should call it the cling ring so we just
I think you may have answered one of my questions and that is you're
anticipating 15,000 cars would would come off the parkway and in transition
and take pressure off of that's right junction that's a great thing all right
any other comments or questions mr. I've been instructed to ask or to state that
we can't name it after bill exactly unless you put it in John Hunt Park
maybe maybe this council would see an exception for mr. clean thank you so
much mr. Davis we appreciate that update and the good work everyone is I can have
two more minutes of this council so let's give you an update also for phase
one update of North Village Town Center so as you know it's proofs been
announced North Village Town Center is a 200 acre of mixed-use retail development
at the intersection we were just speaking of us 231 state route 255 the
project would deliver a little over 650,000 square feet of retail restaurants
medical hospitality fitness along with resident new residential development
progress is moving the city is almost completed some relocation of utilities
hunts for utilities new water line they want to go ahead and get a loop in do
this project there was some sewer that we needed to reroute a drainage ditch
that arrow photography that you saw a regional detention pond that we want to
create all that is about 95% complete so work very quietly has been occurring
with not a lot of fanfare but the fanfare is about to start so we are
scheduling real estate closings both with Target and Home Depot in August in
September so this fall you'll see tilt up concrete walls start to come up out
of that red dirt phase one is scheduled to open in 2027 the whole development
will take about three years to complete it is a lot of land so we will bust that
up into three phases I'm about to show you those phases but phase one will open
next year phase two will start mid to late next year so they'll they'll run a
little bit in parallel as things start to open you'll see new retail hotels and
residential start to catch up so this is the site so you can see some of the
utilities you can see the regional retention pond along the TVA
transmission lines and then we were required to sell this property to remove
any structures on site so there's some it was formerly a farm so there was some
barns and things that that we needed to demo and get off site there was an open
drainage public drainage ditch we've put that underground and rerouted it to
maximize the retail out parcels we could have left it there but for us the amount
of money it took us to relocate versus the out parcels we would get creating
sales tax and property tax it was well worth those utility relocations so again
just another view of this you can see food city to the south you have a proof
so out in front of food city there you see some grass area you have sold one of
those and approved this council so a bavillion express it would be the far
left of half and then we are in negotiations with an entity to purchase
the three out parcels that will bring set down restaurants there we'll bring
that to you very shortly so we've wanted to wait our phone is rung off the hook
but knowing what we were creating across the street we wanted to make sure we got
the highest and best use out of city property and I think we're doing that so
let's kind of walk through everything that's occurring around this
intersection so the white boxes you see that is the phase one you have approved
real estate contracts for everything except the two parcels I've showed you
out front of food city so the red dirt that you see on the west side of the
parkway the kind of triangular piece 16 and a half acres that you see on the
north side of state route 255 those are contractually obligated to our master
developer of target and then directly with Home Depot and then master
developer for the north side once they close in August and September the master
developer will have the authority to bring more public announcements of the
actual end users I can tell you the entire phase one is sold out so every
square foot of phase one which includes about 350,000 square feet of retail is
spoken for and if what I would call it's the best in class type brand names we
all know household names phase two would be in yellow we are starting to work on
that as well as far as public infrastructure the far south portion of
phase two Huntsville Hospital is closed on their property and is in full design
for a new emergency and imaging center it's about a 50 million dollar project
that will break ground next year so they'll be one of the anchors and then
the other anchors we are starting to finalize with our master developer say
master developer with the target as we move west flanking phase one and two as
phase three so we're in final negotiations to secure that property and
starting to talk to retailers on on that piece the orange piece to even further
west so that would be the corner of 255 and Mount Lebanon Road so we're working
with the Harris family and their master developer actually there's a rezoning
action on that project tonight for a planned development that we're very
excited to partner with and bring before this council in the coming months and
then to the far right this last comment I'll make is new residential single
family for sale it's called Camden Place a new residential community that's
under construction this is exactly what we thought we could create five six years
ago as we kept pushing and pushing and pushing to get this project when I say
this project state route 255 underway I am done I'll take any questions Mr.
Davis again thank you thank you to your team and I know it's Watkins you must be
very proud of this I'm absolutely proud and ecstatic and only thing that I don't
like about Shane Davis he won't let me tell anything I have shared some stuff
and she's water secret she's done a great job with that we will look forward
to hearing good news in the future thank you council members